dans la famille Xiaomi je demande le 13
je vous ai parlé du 13 pro il y a pas
longtemps très très grosse smartphone
très intéressant ça c'est la version
chinoise que j'avais acheté je vous
l'avais présenté en avant première donc
ça c'est le 13 pro mais vous avez pas
encore parlé du Xiaomi 13 sur maîtresse
qui se trouvait dans cette jolie petite
boîte toute blanche très centre discrète
très cool avec surtout ce petit logo
Leica et ça c'est vachement intéressant
pourquoi parce que Xiaomi arrive avec ce
gros partenariat avec Leica alors je lui
avais déjà montré avec le douze si j'ai
pas de bêtises avec ce gros capteur de 1
pouce gros capteur de 1 pouce qu'on
retrouve également dans le Xiaomi 13 pro
mais là on retrouve pas dans le Xiaomi
13 de Xiaomi 13 c'est une version plus
light elle a pas ce gros capteur de 1
pouce qu'on avait retrouvé effectivement
dans l'autre version alors bon attention
attention attention ça veut pas dire
qu'il est pas bien ça veut pas dire
qu'il est extrêmement performant ça veut
pas dire qu'il est pas
bon Xiaomi 13 faire le tour complet
regardez s'il est intéressant regardez
c'est pour 1000 balles faut bien
l'acheter ou alors est-ce qu'il faut
passer son tour vous êtes prêts ce que
vous êtes prêts vous êtes prêts on se
parle et je suis à vitesse on y va
maintenant
[Musique]
le Xiaomi 13 il a franchement la même
gueule que le Xiaomi 13 pro sauf qu'il
paraît tout petit à côté je sais pas si
vous le voyez mais lorsque je le prends
en main il paraît un peu tout kiki il y
a vraiment une grosse grosse différence
de taille ça c'est intéressant parce que
si Paris mastoc les Xiaomi 13 pro à côté
pour autant bon il est pas non plus
monstrueux monstrueux il a exactement le
même design alors là où vous retrouvez
en France en tout cas le Xiaomi 13 pro
en céramique blanc
blanc céramique ou noir céramique bon ça
c'est une version que j'ai acheté en
Chine donc elle est un peu différente et
bien là vous le retrouvez dans
différentes couleurs en blanc en noir et
en vert ici c'est le vert et le vert je
l'aime bien il est sympa espèce de petit
verre clair un peu jade très légèrement
avec des petites touches de marron à
l'intérieur personnellement ça me plaît
plutôt bien même design que le Xiaomi 13
pro donc bon jusque là ça me convient
dans la différence qu'on va venir
retrouver c'est que vous avez un écran
plat là où vous avez un écran incurvé
avec le modèle Pro donc si vous aimez
pas l'incurvé que vous préférez le plat
peut-être préférez-vous le Xiaomi 13 au
Xiaomi 13 pro l'écran est aussi un peu
plus petit 6,36 pouces contre
6,73 pouces sur ce truc là c'est très
très mastoc on n'a pas une dalle ltpo on
a toujours de la molette on a un taux
rafraîchissement qui va jusqu'à 120
Hertz en adaptatif ça c'est quand même
plutôt bien donc bon là d'aller bien
l'écran est plutôt cool assez lumineux
également si vous venez le pousser à
fond vous verrez vraiment en extérieur
donc aucun problème là-dessus taux
d'échantillonnage tactile qui va jusqu'à
241 donc pour le gaming on a ce qu'il
faut donc bref on a un écran de très
bonne qualité qui est très sympa aussi
un audio qui déchire mais vraiment
vraiment fort vous allez voir vraiment
ça envoie du bras
ça jette un peu alors bon comme on a
l'habitude sur les smartphones
déséquilibres entre le haut-parleur vous
avez là qui vachement plus puissant et
celui-là qui en parlera en forme et qui
a pas vraiment en stéréoscopie il y a
beaucoup de son
je vous mets au défi de l'écouter à fond
comme ça parce que globalement ça vous
arracher la tronche mais il y a de
l'audio de le bien Atmos ici bref il y a
un truc qui marche très très bien on a
exactement la même performance que ce
que vous avez sur le Xiaomi 13 pro à
savoir un Snapdragon 8 GN2 alors la
différence que vous allez avoir c'est
même technologie de RAM en fait vous
avez de la lpdr5 et en stockage c'est
l'UFS 4.0 bon autant vous dire que ça
aille dernière techno que ça marche très
bien la différence c'est qu'ici vous
avez 8 Go de RAM alors il existe sur le
Xiaomi 13 mais pas en France une version
12 giga de ram mais on l'a pas chez nous
donc on se contentera du giga drame si
vous voulez aller plus loin c'est le pro
avec du 12 Go donc là c'est du 8g de RAM
plus 256 Go de stockage ce qui
globalement fait le taf ça convient bien
la batterie aussi est assez grosse
autonomie est plutôt bonne ça dépend une
fois de plus de vous et de vos usages
alors le truc qui est intéressant ici et
bien c'est que vous avez un plat
pas de mauvaise surprise ici sur mi-way
14 qui pour moi fonctionne bien mais là
où c'est intéressant c'est toute cette
partie photo à venir voir en partenariat
avec Erika alors je sais pas si vous
êtes au fait Leica est un grand
spécialiste de la photo avec des
appareils absolument Dingo et très cher
très haut de gamme et une marque
extrêmement connue qui peut-être la plus
connue dans le monde entier là vous
voyez ou un oppo et un oneplus sont avec
un seul Blade qui sont aussi extrêmement
topissime mais un peu moins connu du
grand public vous avez vivo avec zice
qui aussi très connu mais je pense que
le plus connu ça reste quand même de
loin Leica la grosse différence qu'on va
voir par rapport au tresse prosection 13
Pro vous avez un capteur de 1 pouce 1 50
mégapixels de 1 pouce en gros sur le Pro
vous avez un triptyque 50 mégapixels
grand angle ultra grand-angle tel
objectif 50 mégapixels ça fait pas
rigoler sur le grand angle vous avez un
capteur de 1 pouce donc il capte
vachement de lumière et qui est
topissime là c'est pas la même histoire
alors autant vous avez un grand angle de
50 mégapixels mais c'est pas un capteur
de 1 pouce vous avez un ultra grand
angle de 12 mégapixel et objectif de 10
mégapixels donc on va aller un peu moins
loin c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on va
regarder ensemble tout de suite je vous
emmène au Texas on est à Austin no Texas
j'ai été invité par Marshall et
justement ben j'en ai profité pour faire
plein de photos de Austin de jour et de
nuit alors regardez je vais regarder la
lumière voyez au niveau des ampoules
alors autant devine bien l'ampoule
autant on voit bien effectivement tout
ce petit halo que vous avez autour mais
qui pour moi n'est absolument pas
dérangeant globalement c'est plutôt pas
mal fait chaud on en verra plein
d'autres photos après dans les angles là
vous voyez il perd un petit peu il a un
petit peu plus de mal mais globalement
c'est pas mauvais c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal fichu ici hop là petit
enceinte de Marshall vous avez Austin la
nuit qui est aussi très jolie alors je
trouve que le rendu quand même est assez
qualitatif alors sauf ultra grand-angle
à la nuit qui est pas ouf et qui marche
pas très très bien vous allez voir qu'il
y a quelques petites limites qu'on va
m'y retrouver à droite et à gauche mais
dans l'ensemble tu as fait quand même
plutôt bien fait je trouve j'aime bien
ça c'est joli voyons on va bien les
lumières on voit bien tout derrière les
plantes on a du détail c'est cohérent
c'est joli alors là je vous ai pris un
petit avocatoste pour venir regarder du
point de vue de la nourriture bon ok why
not un petit burritos
[Musique]
fonctionne bien on n'a pas grand chose à
venir lui reprocher ici alors ça c'est
du mode portrait je trouve vraiment très
très cool le mode portrait ça c'est
vraiment la grosse signature Leica qu'on
vient retrouver ici là c'est de base
sans filtre sans rien être très efficace
et très très très joli là vous commencez
un peu avec les filtres les cailles il y
en a différents niveaux du mode portrait
sans vraiment joli sur le noir et blanc
de base en se rapprocher jusqu'à une
douceur là c'est très très sympa il y a
le dernier que j'aime pas et que c'était
fait un petit peu brumeux pas très très
jolie et pour moi ça sert un peu
globalement à rien donc nous l'ont mis
mais voyez regardez le détail derrière
là ça c'est moche quoi en fait alors bon
peut-être qu'il y a mon rouge parce que
vous aimez d'ailleurs dans les
commentaires mais moi je suis pas hyper
hyper fan de ce truc là on continue les
photos là comme ça au grand temps que ça
fonctionne
ultra grand-angle c'est aussi bon on
sera moins bon fatalement que ce qu'on a
et je vous l'ai déjà dit avec le pro qui
ira plus loin que ce gros capteur de 1
pouce et avec ce triptyque 50 mégapixels
mais je trouve qu'ensemble quand même
plutôt pas mal alors après ça sort bien
mais il est quand même cher on est un
tout petit peu moins de 1000 balles et
un tout petit peu moins de 1000 balles
il y a deux trois petites faiblesses au
niveau de la photo je dirais ah pour
1000 balles moyen quoi vous voyez là ce
mode portrait je trouve très très jolie
cette colorimétrie Laïka sauf celle-là
que j'aime pas du tout c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal fichu tout est bien
respecté à droite à gauche alors je vais
essayer d'avancer au max vous voyez la
Capitole directement au niveau de Austin
vous voyez quand on est se rapprocher le
le télé un peu plus de mal hein
fatalement on a une moins bonne
définition ici mais dans l'ensemble
c'est pas me sortir des photos de bonne
qualité qui fonctionne bien qui sont
quand même relativement assez assez
juste et jobstone comme on dirait ici
même pour Jésus ok petit mode portrait
sur ce monsieur qui a bien accepté de
prendre la pause pour moi ça fait le taf
très très clairement le détourage est
vraiment nickel là vous voyez si on
vient regarder là ça détour bien ça
détour bien ici aussi et globalement ça
fonctionnera les petits cactus sont très
jolis également ici ça ça fonctionne
vieille bagnole directement à Austin des
petits porte-clés Elvis voilà on se fait
la tour complet de SxS W et voilà je
trouve vraiment voilà c'est pas mal si
je suis au niveau de la gestion des
couleurs au niveau du piquet au niveau
du détail c'est bien même si
effectivement je trouve que des fois
pour un smartphone à 1000 balles il y a
quelques petites limites notamment au
niveau du téléobjectif qui est quand
même un petit peu en dessous on arrive
quand même à choper des écureuils
lorsqu'on veut venir comme ça vous voyez
bon je vous montre quelques trucs parce
que après tellement vous montrer que ça
c'est un peu compliqué vous voyez en
intérieur là aussi c'est pareil dans
zoomer c'est pas ouf comme ça vous voyez
on va éviter d'aller trop loin avec le
téléobjectif si on n'a pas envie de se
faire mal aux yeux et ribs de bœuf comme
ça vous voyez tout un chien le bus
Marshall que je trouvais complètement
fou ils avaient customiser un truc de
dingue alors en concert et s'en sort pas
trop trop trop trop mal mais c'est vrai
que ça bouge davantage il y a plus de
mal et on va le voir sur le téléobjectif
là il s'en sort plus il est aux fraises
complet alors après j'ai trop zoomer sur
un live il y a pas beaucoup de lumière
très clairement si vous voulez faire des
photos pas mal parce que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de lumière de la nuit vous
prenez votre grand-angle vous évitez du
dragon vous évitez le téléobjectif et la
caméra de selfie je trouve pas ouf non
plus surtout la nuit c'est pas pas
terrible mais sinon on fait des choses
sympas il y a des ambiances qui sont
assez jolies quand même la nuit et que
je trouve assez assez c'est ça c'est
joli ça c'est efficace alors pour moi
ciao maîtresse c'est un smartphone que
je trouve cool que je trouve intéressant
que je trouve jolie mais que je trouve
un peu trop cher aujourd'hui et puis ça
reste compliqué parce qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'acheteurs de Xiaomi viennent
se positionner chez Xiaomi parce que
c'est un excellent rapport qualité-prix
plus dans le milieu de gamme vous voyez
sur la gamme redmi c'est plus là-dessus
qu'on va aller redmi note surtout
puisque redmi mes notes excellent
rapport qualité prix sur la gamme T qui
est aussi très très jolie mais c'est
vrai qu'ils ont fait une belle montée en
gamme avec ce partenariat avec Leica si
on devait choisir entre l'un et l'autre
très clairement je vous dirai rajouter
un peu plus même si c'est quand même
plus cher on est jeudi sur le pro à 1299
90 qui est un thème gros gros gros
budget pour un smartphone là par contre
vous êtes un 999 90 sur la version 8 256
il n'y a pas de version 12 256 chez nous
donc si j'ai mis le bal est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui je vais sur un smartphone
de Xiaomi est-ce que je vais sur le
Xiaomi 13 je pense que c'est là où la
marque aujourd'hui est pas encore assez
forte pour venir emmener du monde dessus
mais néanmoins ce smartphone continue de
convaincre notamment au niveau de la
photo qui est quand même plutôt pas mal
fichu avec ce partenariat avec Leica
mais c'est vrai que si on veut là où il
y a quelque chose de plus surprenant et
de très joli on va aller sur le pro il y
a quand même une grosse différence il y
a quand même quasiment bah il y a 300
balles d'écart entre un modèle et
l'autre mais c'est vrai que ce Xiaomi 13
je trouve joli je trouve très performant
je le trouve endurant vous permettra de
faire beaucoup de gaming d'abord un
smartphone extrêmement réactif avec deux
liades 8 Jen 2 très beau ici qui est
plutôt très bon en photo même si on voit
quelques petites limites s'en sort quand
même vachement bien une fois de plus au
niveau de la photo le synagogue 8 gène 2
et énormément bref il surcharge
également rapidement même si on a pas de
la recherche sur ma route et qu'on a que
de la 63 ce qui est très bien et
largement suffisant pour venir faire ce
que vous voulez donc ce smartphone
j'aime bien alors après je me dis
aujourd'hui sur le marché vous avez
vraiment Samsung en leader vous avez
Apple derrière avec ces iPhone alors
c'est un peu différent parce que si on
va chez Apple c'est que on veut l'os on
veut l'écosystème c'est différent donc
en gros vous avez Samsung Apple derrière
mais c'est un peu différent une fois de
plus et puis après il va arriver en 3e
bonne place ici en France et bien ça va
être Xiaomi avec ses smartphones là qui
est surtout là en volume au niveau des
Red minots et de plein de smartphone il
y a une vraie belle montée en guerre
alors si vous aimez ces smartphones on
peut y aller pour moi il y a aucun
problème bien évidemment ils sont
toujours un petit peu cher puis à
l'inflation qui est là je pense que ça
se ressent énormément aussi au niveau du
prix de ces smartphones là dites le moi
vous dans les commentaires est-ce que
vous pourriez mettre 1000 balles sur un
smartphone de Xiaomi pendant longtemps
Xiaomi ça a été la marque on disait ce
sont des smartphones intéressants mais
pas trop cher et là ils ont vraiment
fait fois à partir de Xiaomi 10 je peux
te dire de bêtises d'augmenter de monter
en gamme d'arriver avec du haut de gamme
et devenir nous surprendre avec des
jolis smartphones comme ça qui
génération génération évolue avec des
partenariats extrêmement sexy notamment
avec ce partenariat Leica que je trouve
très très cool donc est-ce que ça
pourrait vous botter ce que vous
pourriez aller vous sur ce Xiaomi 13
alors une fois de plus si vous voulez y
aller vous pouvez y aller petit
inconvénient je vous montrer rapidement
c'est je sais pas si vous avez bien
c'est les traces de doigts il prend
vachement les traces de doigts c'est un
petit dos comme ça en verre donc ça
c'est pas surprenant donc pensez à venir
le protéger quand même mettez une coque
à l'arrière voilà bon moi je l'aime bien
à vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous pourriez y aller est-ce
que si vous aviez 1000 balles vous iriez
chercher Xiaomi ou est-ce que vous iriez
sur une marque qui vous rassurez
peut-être davantage comment Samsung ou
Apple mais c'est encore une autre
histoire voilà dites-moi ça dans les
commentaires si vous intéresse bien
évidemment je vous mets un lien en bas
dans la description et puis nous on en
parle très bientôt et ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle on parle bientôt les Xiaomi de
pas d'autres marques mais pas de
celui-là celui-là on en a déjà parlé et
je pense qu'on a globalement un peu tout
dit voilà je vous embrasse prenez soin
de vous et à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]